there there is an event called the
podcast movement i had vaguely heard of
it but i don't really know very much
about it it's some conference where
podcasters go and have booths and talk
to one another and since
we here at the daily wire are one of the
largest podcast companies in the world i
think we're number six or number five or
something like that
obviously we had a booth at this
at this event
and
what do you know
the founding editor-in-chief of the
daily wire first show on our network ben
shapiro
shows up to the podcast movement
makes sense one of the most prominent
podcasters in the world would show up to
the podcast movement at the daily wire
booth because the daily wire is one of
the biggest podcast companies
this
this was a really big deal the podcast
movement tweeted out
their heartfelt apology for allowing one
of the most prominent podcasters in the
world to show up
take a listen
ben shapiro briefly visited the pm 22
expo though he was not registered or
expected we take full responsibility for
the harm done by his presence
[Music]
we agreed to sell the daily wire a
first-time booth based on the company's
large presence in podcasting the weight
of that decision is now painfully clear
[Music]
[Music]
during event planning the dangerous
nature of the company's messaging was
overlooked
[Music]
those of you who called this
unacceptable are right podcast movement
has made mistakes the pain caused by
this one will always stick with us
[Music]
yeah thanks for everything you do thank
you so much i appreciate it thank you
i'm excited
[Music]
truly harrowing
it's amazing that those people survived
the podcast movement is is begging for
forgiveness they say those of you who
called it unacceptable are right in nine
wonderful years growing and celebrating
this medium we've made mistakes the pain
caused by this one will always stick
with us
please we take full responsibility
please
if you have any questions we're here to
talk i have questions
and furthermore i do not accept
your apology
i don't think that these tweets cover
the irreparable harm done by ben's
appearance and i want monetary
reparations for that
that's what i want from the podcast
movement the irony of course here about
the podcast movement which is some
two-bit conference who knows i don't
even know where it is
of them attacking ben and the daily wire
is that we are the podcast movement
we are not you not some two-bit
conference us the guys who are actually
some of the biggest podcasters in the
world not just the daily wire i think
what are we number five or number six on
the charts but it's us it's rogan
obviously there's a few other groups
it's really not just us
but it's a handful of us
okay
we're the ones doing it and by the way
the big podcasters skewed
disproportionately to the right or at
least anti-leftist joe rogan's not on
the right but he's not a leftist that's
that's for sure
this company obviously skews to the
right
the reason for that is that the people
for years had been
prevented from accessing conservative
information because of the left-wing
gatekeepers in the institutions of the
media and then podcasting comes around
and podcasting is a pirate ship that's
what adam corolla calls it another guy
who skews
at least a little bit to the right who's
not a leftist he was the pioneer of
podcasting
and the libs are furious about that they
hate that the conservatives are able to
get their message out there in a
relatively freer platform so they're
doing everything they can to shut it
down and they make themselves look
ridiculous because they're afraid of ben
shapiro who is a relatively moderate
center-right voice as mainstream as they
possibly come in america the least
intimidating person on earth who's just
a sort of very polite guy who is
standing around
generously giving of his time to take
photos and
say hey to people and leave
so it's the way they make it sound it's
as though the guy showed up with an uzi
or something like that
hey michael love the show um so recently
i've had the weirdest phenomena which is
that i will be walking my dog and my
baby and my baby son who is super cute
and um
people will comment on how cute the dog
is and like not even acknowledge my son
and
it's just like a really weird thing and
i've noticed there are like two types of
people there are people who acknowledge
your dog and there are people who
acknowledge your human child um and this
also kind of goes hand in hand with me
noticing recently that there are a lot
of people who are walking their dogs in
strollers like as though it's a child
that they're pushing around um just
wonder if this is like a larger trend or
maybe just something in my area i'm not
sure
thanks it's a major trend dogs are the
new kids it's very sad
it should not be the case you should not
treat your dog as your kid you can love
your you should love your dog as your
dog i'm not saying you should be mean to
your dog or not get a dog or not have
affection for your dog no you love your
dog your dog in a way has a soul it's
not a rational soul like a human being
has but a dog has a soul proper to its
nature
but a dog is not a kid
and if you treat the dog as a kid you're
only going to end up unhappy
you should if you can and so desire you
should have a kid if you can't a lot of
people can't have kids and you really
want a kid you should consider adopting
a kid
and
if you
don't want any of those things but you
want a dog you can have a dog but treat
the dog like a dog
don't put the dog in a little stroller i
have friends of mine who do this
it's really really sad you know
something has gone wrong in society
where we just we
coddle the little puppies and we we sort
of stop on the street we say how cute
that little puppy is and then we ignore
the kids when we don't kill them
in the first place yeah something's
going really really wrong there treat
the dog like a dog treat the baby like a
baby i'm glad you like that clip now
look we hit a million subscribers on
youtube i appreciate that that's really
great that we did it
now we gotta hit a billion
a trillion a quadrillion who knows sky's
the limit ring the bell subscribe we'll
see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you